does she have the guts to take on  powerful special interests  no no she is a corporate Democrat uh who  has in fact along with Senator manchin  sabotaged enormously important  legislation so two sides to this of  course number one to the extent  that Kirsten Cinema will caucus with  Democrats and mostly continue voting  with Democrats even if she is a Centrist  corporate Democrat as Bernie says her  vote is still useful and if 60 votes are  needed at least plausibly that's one  fewer Republican vote that would be  necessary fine but at the same time  Bernie is clear about Kirsten Cinema's  political views and as we've seen over  the last two years there's been a lot of  playing koi with her supposed  Independence which is really Center  rightism at the end of the day